マジかよまた増税かそういえばたって誰に
表入れたうんあ俺は選挙に行かないうん
まだ決めていないってことあ違う選挙に
行くつもりはないってことえなんでだって
政治家って年寄りのことしか考えていない
じゃん車超うるさいしいや未だに選挙家を
使うのはそれが年寄りに有効だからだと
思う日本は高齢社会だから俺1人がい
たって何にも変わらないよ高齢社会だけど
投票率もめっちゃくちゃ低いよだから若い
人たちがみんな選挙に行けば選挙に行くっ
てなんかダサいしうんダサいかもしれない
けど選挙に行かないのは年寄りのことしか
考えていない政治家に投票するのと同じだ
よ同元はそんなに日本の政策が嫌いなら
帰ればいいじゃんいや日本の政策が良くな
いって言ってないよ良くないと思うのは
増税のことをぐっているのに選挙に行か
ない高のことだよじゃ同元は誰に表入れた
あ俺は選挙に行ってないはじゃなんでそこ
まで外国人だから投票できない
ああそっかうん分かったよん選挙に行くの
今から嫌いな政治家の悪口を言うからえ
ほらTwitterでバカにしたいやだ
から政治家が気にするのはTwitter
で言われた悪口じゃなくて票の数だよ誰に
票入れるかは俺の勝手だろそうだだから
行ってきていやでもやっぱめんどくさい
どうせまた自民党が勝つからいやだからも
勘弁してくれないその気になったら選挙に
行くからああ分かった
え総理と内閣の年収を上げるふざけんなよ
あそれ俺も見た良くないよねだからもし
だめだ今度は写真付きの投稿にするから
な